yesterday we're having a conversation
about who's a bigger net positive to
society selfish people or selfless
people and I wish you were there to
listen to where this conversation went
because it was so entertaining no way we
need more Southwest people there's a lot
of selfish people but by the time the
conversation was done everyone said
maybe we kind of need more selfish
people in the world because the world is
revolved around selfish people hang Ted
before you judge watch the whole thing
I'm gonna make the case to you at the
end if you say Pat you have no clue what
you're talking about thumbs down if you
say this makes sense give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel let's get
right into it
foreign
let me tell you story about Mario
Aguilar Mario has been with me now for
18 years Mario just had a wedding he got
married this past weekend at my house
beautiful wedding we had a great time
but I want to tell you about a
conversation I had with him five years
ago we're sitting down in the office in
Dallas I said Mario why don't you own a
car cars don't move me how come you
don't own a watch I don't need to have a
nice watch how come you never have money
in savings I don't care if I money if I
have it I give it to other people and
I'm going through like what selfish
goals do you have in place nothing I
said You Realize by you being that way
you're not a positive to the world he
says what do you mean I said if you're
slightly more driven other people win I
win you win your family wins your peers
win your legacy wins your future kids
win everybody wins if you have something
you're going after the world is a better
place if you're in the hunt for some of
your selfish goals so he sits then he
starts thinking about it this guy's
ubering around all over the place he's
wearing the same thing pretty much every
day same shoes same shirts same pants
maybe changes it up here and there but
it's pretty much the same routine things
there's nothing think exciting going on
that he's looking forward to except for
his job we have this conversation Mario
starts making changes he makes a video
about alcohol I think the last time
Mario drank alcohol was three and a half
years ago the video inspires a bunch of
different people and then he says Pat I
want to buy this he buys a nice red
Challenger car comes in it's in the back
of the building I see his eyes light up
so look at what it feels like then a
watch then a nice suit and nice shoes
and you start saving money fast forward
to today he's been living on the water
in Florida for a few years now drives a
nice car has more savings than he's ever
had in his life and I'm talking a few
hundred thousand dollars of savings just
three years ago he had one thousand
dollars in a bank he's got 300 000 in
savings today doing good for himself
just got married but to be a father
parents was here family was here they're
looking at him so proud of him what
happened to this guy just in five years
we don't recognize this guy anymore what
happened to this guy he finally chose to
be a little bit more selfish so watch
this I create this chart yes and I want
you to think about it and kind of grade
yourself as well then I'm going to give
you different levels to it say we have a
chart in this chart that you're looking
at on the top left this is a person
that's a 100 selfish and there's zero
selfless the center where the two
Collide is 50 50 meaning they're 50
selfish 50 selfless and then the person
on the top right is a person that's a
hundred percent selfless meaning they
don't care anything about themselves
everything's about other people and in
the bottom right of somebody that has
zero selfish Gene its meaning all I care
about is as much as I do for you I don't
need anything from anybody so then we
continue this conversation and we said
so which one is more realistic and which
one doesn't exist so we created a chart
and gave it a name with 11 different
levels on where people would be based on
the breakdown and here's what we found
out on the top and the bottom if a
person is a hundred percent selfless and
zero percent selfish on the bottom
that's non-existent it's a myth you know
why it's impossible for a person not to
be selfish if you're not selfish you
don't eat you don't drink you don't take
care of yourself you don't wash you
don't do anything you don't exist so
that's a myth a person cannot be 100
selfless you have to be selfish in order
to live or else you're dead however at
the top when you look at the person
that's 100 selfish and zero percent
selfless those people can actually exist
some of them are criminals sociopaths
they're a danger to society because
they're willing to sacrifice friends
family relative business career it
doesn't matter they're 100 all about
themselves however we looked at at the
different tiers and here's what we came
up with so the next level would be
somebody that is 10 selfish and 90
selfless meaning they're selfish enough
to eat to shower to have a job to do the
basic type of things but they'll agree
with anything anybody tells them these
are people that are weak willed and
generally cowardly they're a net
negative to society one minute they're
having a conversation with somebody
saying did you know what that person
said yeah yeah oh yeah wow I can't
believe it then they'll go to the next
person who completely disagrees with
that person no that person said oh yeah
yeah zero backbone okay there's other
words for it but that's the level of
1090. the next person is somebody that's
20 80. these are folks that are
indecisive they're conforming to
everyone they can't make a decision so I
I don't know I I don't know they're
afraid to make selfish goals and selfish
dreams and I I don't know if this is
good for me I don't want to offend
anybody I'm like just kind of like
conforming again I'm indecise so I'm
staying out of it no problem the 30 70
these are people that are passive Meek
submissive tame still a little more
selfish than others but not enough yet
to start getting some kind of progress
about them there's still more in the net
negative Community then you have 40 60
Supporting Cast very good Supporting
Cast very helpful they're great people
to be having in business to help out
with different structures but during the
4060 Mode still and in the middle is
thinker advisor these are people that
are 50 50. they're good thinkers what do
you think about this I think we should
do this what about that I don't know let
me think about the other person's side
well you know what their their site is
this this side is that so they get you
to think because they can both be
selfish and they're selfless so they're
actually a good person to have on the
team because they can give you both
sides of what to do and what not to do
the synergist and a great teammate is
the 60 40. they have goals they have
dreams they go out there and get it done
they push other people there's somebody
that you're going to want in any great
organization because there are 60 40 and
they have their own things that they
still want to drive to improve the
company improve themselves they're
reading they're improving they're doing
all that they're not content with where
they are so they have bigger selfish
goals than being selfless then you have
the king maker the driver these people
are misunderstood these people are going
to be pushing everybody raising
standards disturbing people but at the
same time there are selfless enough it's
about a bigger dream a bigger cause a
bigger Vision where everybody wins
instead of just being about themselves
that is the 30 mixture of selfless and
selfish to be able to drive the
organization to the next level the next
one is a solopreneur 80 20. selfish 20
selfless they're still in that positive
to society they set an example of
success but they're bad at duplicating
meaning look I'm good I'm not
disrespectful to you I don't hurt you I
don't take advantage of you but I'm just
taking care of myself you do you I do me
and I'm still a net positive to society
not a great leader not great at driving
other people but they're good at for
themselves then you have the next level
which is 90 10. this is a narcissist the
world revolves around them and a
narcissist is actually not a net
positive to society they're bigger net
positive to society than the weak World
cowardly but they're not a net positive
to society it's purely about them and
they're willing to do it generally at
all costs they'll use you as a pawn
they'll look at you as a way to get what
they can get out of you it's not about
how they can help you it's what they can
get out of you rather than making
everybody one at the same time so when
you look at the chart here some people
will come back and say I can't believe
you just said that path you mean to tell
me somebody that's this there we quote
cowardly yes that's generally what
happens you just called me out Pat I
don't like this feeling you're giving me
I'm not doing this to make you feel good
when I create charts like this I go and
think about myself how I was at 18 then
28 and what I have to choose to change
and it wasn't easy then 34 then 35 the
only reason I'm looking at this because
the last 20 years and having been in the
insurance industry haven't trained 40
000 different licensed agents in the
insurance industry you look at traits of
qualities and you say man that guy could
have been very big but man it was all
about him that person could be very big
but dude he couldn't get over the fact
that his wife kept telling him you got
to come home early you got to come home
and if you wanted to please everybody
could have been amazing but her mom
made her feel so guilty all the time and
she fell for it that person could have
been amazing that they could never make
up their minds it was always one day
just one day that that person was an
incredible driver and they built so many
different leaders they pissed a lot of
people off but they also built a lot of
different so if you judge him on success
they helped a lot of people become
financially free these are case studies
on different people now somebody may say
well Pat does this apply to every aspect
of your life you know as a mother if I'm
pregnant shouldn't I be selfless yes
this applies to business let me read a
quote you that maybe this makes sense to
you and this is by a Naseem Talib he
wrote a book called Skin In the game and
he said this he said I am at the federal
level a Libertarian at the state level
of Republican at the local level
Democrat and at my friends and family
socialist pretty weird right wait a
minute you can be a socialist and you
can be a Libertarian and a Republican
and a Democrat yes at different levels
I'm simply giving you who benefits if
you are somebody that you have some
selfish goals your wife wins your
husband wins your kids wins your last
name wins your family ones your heritage
ones the company you're working for wins
the industry wins everybody wins the
challenge with this conversation is this
you ever rented a car and you're like
this is supposed to go 120 miles an hour
how come when I go to 80 it goes back
down that car is a speed governor and
what it does is it doesn't allow you to
go over 80 miles per hour right and the
rental companies do this so they don't
have too many accidents because it's
expensive and done the research to know
what the numbers they don't want drivers
to go about because it's not their car
they don't treat it like their car the
reason why this chart is being shared
with you is you may be watching this and
you may say man I'm kind of part of the
narcissist community no problem bring
your Governor down 270 okay and no
anytime you go above 70 people don't
like to be around you because it's all
about you but you may be somebody that's
at the other level you're a little bit
of a cowardly weak will or you conform
maybe you need to bring your Governor up
and start talking about your selfish
goals like Mario did you know what
happened to his life it changed almost
everybody I know that's bitter they tend
to come more from a place of selfless
than a little bit of selfish the world
is a better place if you have a little
bit more selfish Gene in you than
selfless Gene in you everybody around
you wins if you have that so if you want
the net positive index chart sent to you
text the word selfish to
310-340-1132 once again text the word
selfish to
310-340-1132 we will send the PDF to you
so you can take a look at it and score
yourself having said that the video I
want you to watch is a video I've not
recommended before it's Mario's video
when he talks about what happened the
day he chose to stop drinking alcohol if
you've never seen this video this is a
perfect example of somebody who can go
from having a life that was chaotic to
not having an amazing wedding one of the
most beautiful weddings I just had went
to this past Saturday which was
phenomenal the man's life has changed
because of the decisions he made if
you've never watched it
click you to watch the video and if you
love the video send Mario a direct
message at Aguilar social either on
Twitter or Instagram take care everybody
bye bye
foreign